The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
Today, we will
consider problems where
the solutions are
standing waves.
So the first problem I'm going
to do is shown over here.
What we have is a string
attached at both ends.
The length of the
string is L. And it
is distorted in
this strange shape.
The dimensions are
given everywhere.
It's symmetric about
the middle, OK?
Somehow miraculously,
it's held fixed.
You could imagine maybe sort
of nails nailed here and here
and fingers holding there.
And then miraculously,
we let go, all right?
And the question
is after we let go,
what is the wavelength of
the lowest mode that is not
excited, the amplitude of the
lowest mode which is excited?
And finally, the
question is, what
is the shape of this string
at this strange time?
Now, then what do they tell us?
That this is an ideal
lossless string,
which has a mass per
unit length of mu.
It has a uniform tension T.
For all the equations to work
and the derivation
of the wave equation,
you have to assume that the
angle is sine angle, et cetera,
is equal like this, which
is-- you look at this
and say, holy smoke.
How can this be the case?
Well, of course, this is
an idealized situation.
In reality, this would
be very, very small
compared to that, all right?
And one would have to have
some curvature at these points.
The differences will
be, the real situation
from this idealised
one, will only
differ in some very
high frequencies.
So the first approximation,
one can almost
imagine that it's
possible to set this up.
And this assumption, as
I told you, initially
is the system, at t
equals 0, is stationary.
OK.
The above, as I was just saying,
is really highly idealized.
It is almost a
mathematical representation
already of a real situation.
So you could imagine
this almost being
a mathematical description
of this situation.
And what makes it physics
rather than the mathematics
is that string obeys
the wave equation.
It obeys this wave equation.
Once I've told you that
that picture on that diagram
satisfies the wave equation
where V is a constant given
by this quantity, we've
now converted this problem
completely to mathematics.
One thing to notice, this
is the phase velocity
of propagation of a
progressive wave on a string.
So here, that time,
they ask us in part
C-- is the shape of the string
at a time L over V from time
equals 0.
So we're now solving this
problem, mathematics problem.
We know that if you have
a coupled oscillator,
there are normal mode
solutions, solutions
where every oscillator
is oscillating
with the same
frequency and phase.
For a system, a
continuous system
like this is, an infinite
number of identical oscillators
in a straight line for a
string like that, the most
general solution
will also be-- one
will be able to represent
it as a superposition
of normal modes.
Of course, if you
look at such a system
and you distort this
from equilibrium,
you can set up an infinite
different varieties
of solutions.
But what I'm saying is that
any one of those solutions
however complicated,
one could always
reduce it to a superposition
of normal modes.
In particular, if you
study the solutions
of a system like this,
one dimensional system
like that, you will find
that the normal modes are,
in fact, standing waves
which are sinusoidal.
So I've written for you here
a completely general solution
to a string.
And you can write it, as
I said, as a superposition
of an infinite number of normal
modes, pretty complicated.
It tells you at every
position on the string
and at every time what
is the displacement.
You can calculate the
transverse velocity
by differentiating, et cetera.
It just tells you everything
about the oscillations
of a string.
This is not any old string.
Because we are told
some things about it.
We are told it's
attached at both ends
so that string has no
displacement in the Y
direction at x equals 0 and
at x equals L. For all times
t this equation will satisfy
that string-- doesn't matter
even what distortion
it is-- provided
we put some constraints
on these various constants
such that this is true.
Well, you can almost
do it in your head.
If you look at this, all
these-- if for all times, at x
equals 0, y is 0, this
term, B of N, has to be 0.
So this, you could forget about.
And you're down to this.
Furthermore, you
know it has to be
0 at x equals L. That puts
a constraint on k of n.
So your solution
then is of this form.
This is any arbitrary constant.
For the wave equation,
you can show for a string
that these two are related
through the phase velocity.
And so once you've
established this,
then we've got that constant.
So you're still left with
quite a number of constants
and an infinite series where
the An can be anything.
This phase can be anything.
It's always useful
to check yourself.
There are some
things you can check.
So for example, let's consider
the n equals 1 harmonic,
that normal mode, the
first normal mode.
If you look at this, it's
clear that the wavelength
of that harmonic is 2L.
If you look at this, the period
of that harmonic is 2L over v.
Period is 1 over frequency,
or frequency is 1 over period.
So the frequency is v/2L.
We know that for harmonic
waves or standing waves
that lambda times F
is the phase velocity.
Let's check it here,
multiply lambda by F,
and you get that
this is satisfied.
So at least this
is a quick check
that we haven't made
some stupid mistake.
All right, so this
satisfies any string
of length L which is
tied at both ends.
But our string is
not any string.
We've said that initially, at
t equals 0 for all positions,
the string is stationary.
So our description of it must
take into account the equation
which describes this
shape of the string
and it must have this
boundary condition, OK?
So we take this
equation-- so far,
we've reduced it to
that-- differentiate it
with respect to time, get this.
And that's an easy-- we
just have to differentiate--
the cosine gives you minus sine.
OK, so you end up with this.
And this, we know is 0.
It's 0 at-- I'm sorry,
this is a t equals 0.
I'm sorry.
We know that at t equals
0 at every position
x-- we said that.
We're holding this string
with nothing moving.
At t equals 0, it's stationary.
We then let go.
So this is 0.
And if you look
at this, this will
be 0 at all values
of x at t equals 0,
only if all values
of phi n is 0.
So notice, gradually, by making
use of all the information we
have about the situation--
what string it is, where it's
attached, how long it is,
what is its motion at t
equals 0-- we're gradually
getting rid of the constants
or determining them.
Now that phi n is
0, I go back to this
and rewrite the equation.
And now, we've ended up that
the general equation which
describes a string
which has length L tied
at both ends, stationary
at t equals 0 is this.
An is still to be determined.
We have not made use, so
far, of the information what
is the shape of the
string at t equals 0.
That's what we'll do next.
But before I do this, I
just want to make a comment.
In many books,
problems, et cetera,
you'll find people starting
with this equation.
And you'll be wondering, how
on Earth-- is this the most
general equation
for string problems?
No.
The answer why they
started with this
is, often without telling
you, doing all this analysis
in their head.
This is only true
for a situation
where this string
is tied at both ends
and initially stationary.
That forces you to that.
And An now is now
not determined.
And in order to find out the
value of An-- in other words,
the amplitude of the
different normal modes--
we have to make use of the shape
of the string at t equals 0.
And that's what we'll do now.
All right, so now,
I'm going to make
use of the last bit
of information I have.
And since that defines the
physical situation completely,
there'd better be enough
to find all the constants.
There should be nothing left.
They should be then
completely determined.
So first of all, I said we
didn't make use of the shape
at t equals 0.
At t equals 0, cosine of 0 is 1.
So what we know is that the
string shape is given by,
from here, by this equation.
So this tells us that--
this is a description
of the shape of
the string in terms
of an infinite series
of sinusoidal functions.
OK, we notice this tells us the
shape of the string at every X
position at t equals 0.
So I look at that,
the original shape.
And I can describe
it mathematically.
y of x at time equals 0 is
0 at all points from one
end of the string to where
the distortion starts.
And it starts at 3/8 L if
you look at the diagram.
Then from position x
of 3/8 L to x is 5/8 L,
the string is straight again,
and its displaced by a distance
H. And afterwards, past
the 5/8 L, it's back to 0.
For a second, let's go
back and just look at that.
So we're talking about
this shape, right?
It's 0, 0 in Y, and then jumps
to H between 3/8 L and 5/8 L.
This shape, when
you let go, that
will determine the amplitude
of the different normal modes
that are important in the
oscillation of that system.
OK, so we must determine these
infinite number of constants.
At first sight, it looks
like an impossible task
if it wasn't for a
brilliant mathematician
in the 18th century,
Fourier, who
made a relatively simple
but incredibly important
observation.
When applied to this
problem, it is the following.
He realized that one can
do the following trick.
If you take this
function, sine n pi
over L x to 1 which is
describing our shape
over there, if you multiply
it-- and by the way,
n-- I'm just reminding you--
goes from 1 to infinity.
It's 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, et cetera.
If you take this function
and you multiply it
by a similar function, but
with different value of m,
then this integral from one
end of the string to the other,
is equal to 0 if this,
the m you've chosen here,
is different than n.
Try it.
I don't want-- a good
exercise for yourself.
Take this function.
And do the integration, and
you'll find it comes out to 0.
It's not hard to do.
So that is 0 if n
is not equal to m.
On the other hand,
if m equals n--
so this is the integral of
sine squared n pi over L--
it comes out to be L/2.
You can do it for yourself.
This trick allows us to
solve for all values of An.
Now, let me tell
you, I did not do
this in-- the Fourier
trick-- in general.
If you go into books,
you'll find the formulation
of this trick known
as Fourier's theorem
for any periodic function.
The advantage of learning it,
how to do it for any function,
you don't have to do
this integral every time.
Because suppose our
function turned out
there to be a cosine, we
would have to then figure out,
what do I multiply it by to
make this come out so simply?
As I say, the
advantage is then you
can use formulate
in books, et cetera.
There's nothing wrong with that.
It is good.
And the way one changes a
physical situation into one
where you can apply Fourier's
theorem, which only applies
to periodic functions, is
to take your original shape,
and out of it, create
a periodic function.
Once you've done that, you
can use Fourier's theorem.
I've, in this particular
case because I find it easier
to explain it, simply
essentially derived
the Fourier theorem for
this particular problem.
For this particular
problem, the function
by which you multiply
this is sine m pi.
OK, once you've realized
that this is true,
I can go back and use it
to determine every An.
I go to this function.
I multiply both sides in
turn by sine m pi over L
for every n where I want to find
the value of An, for each one.
So I have to do
an infinite number
of integrals in principle.
But often you don't need
to know every value of n.
You may want to
know each one of An
is the amplitude
of the harmonic.
You may be interested
in what is the amplitude
of the first harmonic solution
or the second or third.
However many you want, so
many integrals you have to do.
No magic.
You're basically solving
infinite number of equations.
And if I apply this
to our problem,
we find that An is equal
to 2/L. It's from here.
The integral of 0 of
2L of y sine at dx.
Right?
All I'm taking, I'm multiplying
both sides of this equation
by sine of m pi L over
x and integrating them
both from 0 to L.
On one side, you
end up with An and on the
other, 2/L times this integral.
Then once you've done this
integral, you know the answer.
In our case, y of x of
0 is particularly easy.
It's 0 in this range,
0 in this range,
and a constant for the rest.
Well, over the part of
the range where it's 0,
if I multiply
something by 0, it's 0.
And so I only have to do
this integral over the range
where y of x for 0 time is H.
So I have to do this integral.
And now I have reduced
the situation that every n
that we are
interested in, we can
calculate by doing
this integral.
So in principle, we've solved
it for all values of n.
So finally, I can
answer the question.
So the first question was
what lowest value of n
for which An is 0.
Well, let's start.
Take number 1, 2, 3.
And for n equals 1, this
integral is not equal to 0,
because what you have
to do is you basically
are integrating
this-- for n equals
1, that's what the sine
pi over L x looks like.
You're integrating that
and multiply it by 0.
And here, you're multiplying
by a constant and 0.
Clearly, this is not
going to give you a 0.
Let's take the second
one, the second harmonic
in this calculation.
You're multiplying
this y by this function
and integrating it, OK?
Notice the sine function
is symmetric about 0
and so is this symmetric.
Except here, this is an
anti-symmetric function.
So the sine is negative
to the right of the middle
and positive to the left.
If I multiply this positive by
that, I get a positive number.
If I multiply this by that,
I get a negative number.
The two are equal.
And so the integral
across there is 0.
So n equals 2 is the lowest
harmonic for which An is 0.
When I let that string
go, the second harmonic
will not be excited.
Which is the lowest n for which
it is excited-- in other words
that An is not equal 0.
Well, I told you when n
equals 1, clearly An is not 0.
So that will be excited.
So the first harmonic
will be excited.
What is the amplitude?
Well, we have to calculate it.
I told you, every An--
I told you what it is.
I have to do some work.
So you take A of 1 is 2/L. The
integral from that to the H
times this function
where n is 1, all right?
And that, fortunately, is
an easy integral to do.
Integrate the sine,
you get the cosine.
And putting in the limits,
you get this answer.
So that is our answer to
that part of the problem.
The final part of
the problem was
they said, OK, I
have this shape.
I let go.
What will that shape
look like at a time
was L-- in the problem,
the time was L times
the square root of mu over T.
T's the tension in the string.
But I know that square
root of mu over t
is 1/d, the phase velocity.
So they ask us to calculate
the shape of that string
at the time which is the
length of the string divided
by the phase velocity
of progressive waves
on the string.
OK, now we know completely what
is the shape of the string.
It is this formula.
This is the formula
that tells us
what the string looks like
at all places, all times.
From our knowledge
of this integral,
depending where it's
symmetric or anti-symmetric
sinusoidal function
about the center,
we know that every
second one will be 0.
So this sum now,
I've only summed
for n equals 1, 3,
5, 7, et cetera.
The terms n equals 2, 4, 6, et
cetera, will have 0 amplitude.
But this now describes our
situation in its entirety--
because I've now not only know
the spatial shape, but also
as a function of time.
So this describes
what it was at time t.
What will it be if I increase
the time-- let's start from 0,
and I go to a time L/v?
All right, well, if this
changes from 0 to L/v,
this changes to cosine n pi.
But you know that for n
equals 1, 3, 5, et cetera,
cosine of n pi-- in other
words, at pi, at 3 pi,
et cetera-- is minus 1.
So at this later time,
every term in this expansion
has changed signs.
But it's exactly the same
series, except it's minus 1
here.
So what has happened
to the string?
It is exactly the same
shape with an opposite sign.
So with the string, instead
of being up here like that
like it was over here, it's
flipped over like that.
Without doing any more work,
I can conclude that simply
because I have the same series
as before with a negative sign.
So that is the answer.
So I've solved the problem.
But at this instance, I just
want to digress for a second
and tell you this
actually is a problem
that we could have almost
done all by thinking alone.
It wasn't necessary to do big
fraction of the work we did.
The only part which
there was no choice
is this amplitude [INAUDIBLE].
Because I could have gone
back, scratched my memory
and knowledge, and
said, look, hold on.
When I have been a
string, I could always
analyze it in terms
of normal modes.
But also, we know that we
can describe the solutions
in terms of progressive waves.
The two are equivalent
to each other.
It's not extra solutions.
But by adding
appropriately normal modes,
I can get a superposition
of progressive waves.
I can use the uniqueness
theorem to see
if I've got a solution
which represents
the situation at hand.
If you look at the
original problem,
if you look at this problem,
this is stationary, all right?
So I could imagine this
solution being the superposition
of two progressive waves
that look like this but half
the amplitude, one moving
to the left and one
moving to the right.
As they overlap--
in other words,
I have two waves, one like
this moving to the right,
and one like this
moving to the left.
If I add them, I'll
get this distortion,
which is stationary.
Therefore, if I
solved the problem
for each one of these
progressive waves and add them,
I'll get the answer to this.
It'll satisfy all the
boundary conditions.
By the uniqueness
theorem, it will
be the correct description
of what happened.
And then with
that, I can predict
what will be the
shape at any time.
So for example, in
the time they ask L/v,
a progressive wave
will move a distance L.
So the wave over
here, which was going
to do the right would hit this
boundary-- that pulse-- would
flip over.
And you know that this
string is fixed there.
What happens if a pulse
comes to a fixed end?
Imagine you are
causing the pulse.
You are the forcewave
moving along
which causes the distortion.
When you come to the
rigid end, you're pulling.
It won't give.
So the only way to happen,
the string will pull you down.
So you'll flip over.
So this pulse, when
it hits this end,
will flip over
upside down, and then
progress this way upside down.
This one will go to this end,
flip over, and progress back.
By the time t has changed
by L over the velocity,
those flipped pulses would have
come back here and overlapped,
but upside down.
And so this would have flipped.
By this kind of analysis, if
you use your wits about it,
sometimes you can solve
more difficult problems
quickly by using all the
knowledge you have about waves,
the propagation, et cetera.
Probably a good time to stop.
Thank you.